EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU WELCOME
TO THE FIRST HEARING OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WITH THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
ON BEHALF OF OUR AMAZING AND
DEDICATED AT COMMITTEE STAFF
TEAM AND TO ALL OF THE SENATORS-
HAPPY WISHES AND WARM WISHES
FOR. A SUCCESSFUL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND
SENATE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE WILL BE FORMALLY
COMING TO ORDER IN RESPONSE THE
KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE
TORS AND EMPLOYEES WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LIMIT NON ESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TOO SOCIAL
DISTANCING HENCE. THE DICE INTO
THE MASKS THAT WERE ALL WEARING-
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE THEIR
RIGHTFUL ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE GONNA
BE HOSTING THE COMMITTEE HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL OF COURSE WE'RE
GONNA BE HAVING FOLKS CHIMING.
IN LISTENING HERE TODAY AT B. R.
LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS THAT WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC INTO THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING THAT
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE INVITE YOU TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT. HERE'S THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT
UP ON THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE SIMPLY DIAL
844-291-6364 WITH THE CODE.
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY WE'RE GONNA ASK
YOU TO PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE
THAT YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE NOW IN THE
UNLIKELY EVENT THAT WE HAVE SOME
ON THE- BECOMES THIS. WHETHER
IT'S ON A TELECONFERENCE LINE.
AND ARE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THAT WE WILL ASK THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE OR IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. DAYS IN
GERMANY WE HAVE A PRETTY QUICK
AGENDA HERE TODAY WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AND
THERE ARE. NO BILLS PROPOSE FOR
CONSENT BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS LET'S
GET THAT CORVUS DEVILISH. MR
GRINNELL HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU
SIR IF YOU WANT TO CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE YOUR WIRE
PRESIDENT SENATOR NIELSEN HERE
OPEN PRESIDENT SENATOR DURAZO.
TORONTO PRESIDENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER WEINER
PRESIDENT IF THEY CAN GET A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED THIS
IS GOING TO BE THE CASE. THE
FOLKS THAT YOU SEE HERE ON THE
DICE ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA BE
MOVING STRAIGHT INTO OUR BILL
LOW TODAY WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
SENATOR FORTINO- IT CENTER DRIVE
SO I SAID I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A
BILL. ON MOTION PICTURE TAX
CREDITS MY RIGHT AS SENATOR ALSO
. ABSOLUTELY AND SO- HER WISH IS
GRANTED HAPPY NEW YEAR US
INTERPRET YOU KNOW WE WELCOME
YOU TO BE A PRESENT ON SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE. IN CENTER
POINT YOU KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING
IS WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM SENATOR STERN ON
THIS BILL AS WELL CENTER
FOURTEEN ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND WHEN I STARTED THE NEW YEAR
I SAID I WANTED TO GRANT ALL
OFFENDED ARISES WHICH IS SO I'M
HAPPY TO. BE CHECKING THAT OFF
THE BOX ONCE YOU HAVE YOUR
DEVICE. THERE YOU GO THAT BOX
ALREADY. EXACTLY AUTHENTIC NOT
AWKWARD HERE WE GO WE GOT HER A
LOT. SO I'M HAPPY TO THAT'S
RIGHT. HAPPY TO SERVE THAT
PURPOSE- SO IT'S GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME BE
HERE TO PRESENT THE SP FORTY
FIVE. WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY
CONTAINED. WHICH WE PASSED LAST
YEAR'S SP ONE FOR FORD TO EXPAND
THE FILM. AND TELEVISION TAX
CREDIT WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. THIS
YEAR WE'RE BACK- WITH US BEFORE
EIGHTY FIVE AS A EXTENSION OF
THE CURRENT. THREE POINT OH TAX
PROGRAM UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY I'M
PLEASED THAT- CENTER STERN WILL
BE SAYING A FEW WORDS AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR- ALSO SOME
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE CORREO. AND
SAM A SENATE MINORITY LEADER
WILL- AND OBVIOUSLY ANYONE ELSE
WHO WANTS TO COME ON BOARD WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE. MORE CO
AUTHORS- AS AMENDED SB FORTY
FIVE SIMPLY EXTENDS THE TAX
CREDIT THE SUCCESS WE'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA FILM FILM TAX CREDITS
HELP. BRING SIGNIFICANT
PRODUCTION BACK TO OUR STATE
WHERE THEY BELONG IT'S CREATED A
MIDDLE CLASS LARGELY- LABOR
REPRESENTED UNION JOBS- AND IT
HAS PAID FOR ITSELF. OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN WITH
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO
OUR STATE. WITH THE EXTENSION OF
THE CURRENT TAX CREDIT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE. AND CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE COUNTRY IN FILM
PRODUCTION WHERE IT SHOULD BE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF SPEAKERS FROM. LABOR
WHO ARE GOING TO BE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR STERN. WHO IS NO
STRANGER TO THE FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY WOULD ALSO
LIKE T SAY A FEW WORDS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AN APPOINTEE NOW
WE'RE GONNA BRING UP SENATOR
STERN FIRST AND FOREMOST FOR
GONNA DISINFECT THE PODIUM IN
BARGAINING BY SINISTER AND GET A
SAY A FEW WORDS SINISTER WERE
GREAT FOR THE HEARING COMMITTEE
TODAY. GOOD MORNING SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
TO OUR LEAD AUTHOR AND- GUIDE
THROUGH- NOT JUST- THIS CURRENT
BILL BUT THROUGH LAST YEAR'S
EFFORTS- WE PUT OUT A LIFELINE
TO THE HARD WORKING PEOPLE OF
THE FILM AND TELEVISION INDUSTRY
WHO HAVE FRANKLY TAKEN IT ON THE
CHIN- AND IN SOME CASES MUCH
WORSE- IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS WE KNOW
PRODUCTION STILL HURTING- THE
INDUSTRY IS. GRINDING IT OUT
EVERY DAY TO TRY TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN BUT- THIS INDUSTRY FEEDS
FAMILIES- AND IT'S THE FOLKS
BELOW THE LINE NOT THE FOLKS
ABOVE THAT YOU SEE ON THE SILVER
SCREEN TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN SO I
THINK PROVIDING SOME DAY LIKE TO
THEM AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
HERE- AND LOOKING BEYOND JUST A
YEAR TO YEAR ISSUE AND- AND
EXTENDING THIS TAX CREDIT OUT-
THROUGH THIS DECADE. IS GOING TO
BE THE CRITICAL LONG TERM SIGNAL
WE NEED TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO SUPPORT WORKING PEOPLE
I'M NOT JUST IN LOS ANGELES BUT
THINKS THE MECHANICS OF THIS
BILL ALL THE WAY UP TO THAT
NORTH COAST. THOSE UP LIFT
CREDITS THE MECHANICS HERE
REALLY WORK AND- I THINK IT'S
GOING TO WORK FOR EVERYBODY SO
WE WANTED TO BE HERE PRECIADO
THE DIFFERENCE FROM MY COLLEAGUE
GOT TO ALLOW ME A- CO AUTHOR
THIS WITH HIM AND- WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. SO MUCH ANDERSON
WERE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY AT AND DO APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP. THAT CENTERPOINT
TINO HAS DEMONSTRATED ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. FACING GERMAN
I'M GONNA BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK EACH OF OUR LEAD
LEAD WHICH IS TO BE TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES OR LESS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP THE HEARING NOW TO. NOT
MISS VEGA CAITLIN VEGA THE FLOOR
IS YOURS GOOD MORNING HAPPY NEW
YEAR. GOOD MORNING HAPPY NEW
YEAR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
CAITLIN VEGA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA I ASKED THE COUNCIL
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE. ARE WE WANT TO
START BY JUST THINKING AND OF
COURSE IF YOU KNOW FOR HIS LONG
STANDING COMMITMENT TO THIS
PROGRAM. AND ALSO QUITE SENATOR
STERN FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA IRP COUNCIL
REPRESENTS FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
SKILLED WOMEN AND MEN WHO WORK
ON FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OUR MEMBERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
THE INDUSTRY. AND THE CRAFT
PEOPLE AND TECHNICIANS WHO MAKE
WHAT HAPPENS ON SCREEN POSSIBLE.
TEN YEARS AGO THERE WAS ALMOST
NO FILM OR TELEVISION PRODUCTION
IN CALIFORNIA. HISTORIC HOME OF
THE INDUSTRY. EVEN WHEN OUR
DRAMATIC TV PROGRAM WHEN THE
STAPLE IN THE STATE. HAD LEFT
FOR INSTANCE OF. WHERE THAT
PLANE TWENTY FOURTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN ENACTED A CALIFORNIA FILM. AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. THAT HAD OUT LIKE A- TO
PUT BILLION TO FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION. WOULD HAVE GENERATED
NEARLY TWENTY BILLION AND
EXPENDITURES IN CALIFORNIA. AN
ATHLETE PROMISED TWENTY NINE
TELEVISION SERIES HAVE RETURNED
TO CALIFORNIA. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE PROGRAM HAS RESULTED IN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN QUALIFIED
WAGES PAID TO BELOW THE LINE
SKILLED WORKERS LIKE OUR
MEMBERS. AT THE UNION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING GREATER
DIVERSITY IN OUR INDUSTRY AND
THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM INCLUDED A
NEW CAREER PATHWAYS. COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WHO HAVE BEEN UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THE INDUSTRY.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF FEATURES
THAT MAKE THIS PROGRAM A MODEL
IN TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY UNLIKE MOST TAX
CREDIT IT IS CAPPED ALLOCATED
HAS A FENCE THAT DATE AND IS
EXPLICITLY DESIGNED TO BRING
BACK AND RETAIN GOOD JOB IN
CALIFORNIA THIRTY SECOND CREDIT
ALEX. IT'S ALLOCATED AFTER
PRODUCTION ONLY FOR BELOW HE
LINE WORKERS AND BECAUSE OF HIGH
UNION DENSITY GOES TO CREATE
GOOD UNION JOBS. AT THE FORTY
FIVE LYNCH INSTABILITY FOR THIS
INDUSTRY WE THANK YOU MR CHAIR
FOR ALL YOU HAVE DONE TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
INDUSTRY AND IN PARTICULAR THE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN WHO MAKE
IT FRIENDLY URGE YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I
THINK AGAIN HAVING HEARING
PROCEDURE IS TODAY WE HAVE. ONE
LAST LEAD WITNESS AND THAT IS
MISTER GUS MENTION GUSMAN FROM
BRIAN GROSSMAN AT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IT MR GUSMAN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEED AND HAPPY NEW YEAR. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU AS WELL.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- WE TOO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK. SENATE
REPORT TEEN OVER FOR CHAMPIONING
MEDICINE. AND SENATOR STERN AND
ALL THE OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED US OVER THE YEARS.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM. THE TEAMSTERS REPRESENT
MULTIPLE CRASH IN THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA'S FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY. AND THIS
INCENTIVE HAS BEEN REALLY A
GODSEND. TO ALL WHO WORK IN AND
AROUND. IN CENTER ORIGINAL
ENACTMENT WHICH SOME. IN THE
UNIONS ARE FOUR TO THE BAD OLD
DAYS. OUR MEMBERS STRUGGLE TO
GET ENOUGH WORK TO PROVIDE THEM
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE OCTOBER FIRST
FORCED TO RELOCATE TO OTHER
STATE. FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME
OR EVEN PERMANENTLY TO FIND WORK
. BACK IT ALL CRASHED IN THE
INDUSTRY AND THERE REALLY WAS A
DANGER OF PERMANENTLY LOSING.
THE PERSONNEL INFRASTRUCTURE THE
EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO MEET HAD
MEANINGFUL PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA
. FAST FORWARD TO NOW WE HAVE A
REVITALIZED INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA
TELEVISION FILM PRODUCTION HAS
THRIVED IN EVEN SURVIVE THIS
PANDEMIC LARGELY BECAUSE OF THIS
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. OUR MEMBERS
CAN NOW EXPECT LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
THERE IS A REAL PATHWAY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE LOOKING TO MAKE A
CAREER IN THE INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. REALLY QUICKLY ABOUT
WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET NOW. FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION IS PLANNED WELL IN
ADVANCE. OF THE ACTUAL START OF
PRINCIPAL PHOTOGRAPHY.
IMPORTANTLY THIS INCLUDES
BRINGING OUT FINANCING AND HOW
TO PAY FOR. A TELEVISION SERIES
PRODUCTION WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE
TO PLAN BEYOND ONE SEASON AND AS
WE EXTEND YOU KNOW GETTING INTO
THIS CURRENT SIGNS THAT WE ARE
REALLY RUNNING UP AGAINST.
THIRTY SECONDS. YOU KNOW.
ABSOLUTELY THE TEAMSTER MEMBERS
AND REST OF AND THE REST OF THE
WORK FORCE YOU KNOW WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DEPEND ON THE
STABILITY OF THIS PROGRAM AND-
YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO REAP THE
BENEFITS OF THE SUCCESS OF ITS
SUCCESS. AND LASTLY I WOULD
MENTION THAT OUR FIRM ALSO
REPRESENTS SAG AFTRA AND- ****
AFTER STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS
MEASURE AS WELL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER GROSSMAN
AGAIN HAVING YOU TO YOU TO
LISTEN GERMAN WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'RE GONNA SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HERE IN THE ROOM IF YOU ARE
IF YOU COULD PLEASE. COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD MORNING SIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GET YOUR FIRST AND LAST-NAME- AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL TO FORCE YOUR SIR. THANK
YOU MR. MEMBERS TRANSMIT ON
BEHALF OF THE WALT DISNEY
COMPANY OF SUPPORT. IT'S GOOD TO
SEE THANK YOU SO MUCH- PRE SHEET
YOU BEING HERE TODAY LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED TO. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. HERE IN C. NINE LAYS IN
GENERAL WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH OUR
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR GOOD
MORNING TO YOU AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR. LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU TODAY. IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
NOW. ABSOLUTELY IT'S A GENEROUS
WISH TO QUEUE UP FOR COMMENT-
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND FIRST WE GO TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. BELIEVES THEY
WENT THIS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MEMBER LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS JAMES
THEREAFTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABOR'S STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. SHARING MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL ALBRECHT REPRESENTING
WARNER BROTHERS STUDIOS WARNER
MEDIA TRANSPORT THANKS MICHAEL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT
E'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SHARE- THIS IS PAT JOYCE ON
BEHALF OF NBC UNIVERSAL AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HE SO MUCH AS
GOVERNOR SCHOLAR. NEXT TO THE
TREE LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU KAREN AND
IT ENDED UP BEING THE TEAMSTERS
LOCAL THREE NINETY NINE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I HAVE BEEN TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS EDUARDO MARTINEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION INSTRUCTED PORT MANY
THANKS TO SET AN APPOINTMENT UP
OR IF THE- GOOD GOOD HERE HOSTED
ONE OF THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO THE
TO LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI REBECCA RYAN INTERNATIONAL
ECONOMIC TARGET FOR GUILD IATSE
LOCAL SIX HUNDRED STRONG SUPPORT
AND THANKS TO THE ENATOR KERR
BRINGING THAT FORWARD THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. KATHY GARMIN G. REPRESENTING
THE ENTERTAINMENT UNION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
ECHO THE THANKS NUMBER FOURTEEN
THANKS KATHY LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO THE TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PETER WARD- WITH VIKA THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT'S CORRECT CAR.
NOT TO THE TO LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COLOR ONE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT LINE. AN EXCELLENT
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
DUG BONY WITH IATSE LOCAL EIGHT
NINE TO THE COSTUME DESIGNERS
GUILD AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH I WANNA PAUSE HERE
FOR A MOMENT AND RECOGNIZE AND
WINTERS IN WINTER. REMOVABLE ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR FOR SENATE BILL FORTY
FIVE. WE WILL CONTINUE TAKING
TESTIMONY BUT DO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A MOTION. ON
THE FLOOR AT LET'S GO BACK TO
OUR CALLERS INTERNATIONALLY. THE
NEXT LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING LESLIE
SIMMONS WITH THE ANIMATION GUILD
IATSE LOCAL EIGHT THIRTY NINE IN
SPORT. THANK YOU LESLIE LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT LINE MODERATOR. THE
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS
HAPPY NEW YEAR THIS IS DOUG
SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS FOR CALLING
INTO BRIGITTE LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. IN THE FOOD LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MY NAME AT THE
JOHN ELLIS JUNIOR REPRESENTING I
GOT THE LOOK LADY STUDIO PRESS
PRESS SERVICE AND FIRST AID
PERSON STANDING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY BUCKS A
GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A
PHONE CALL TODAY SIR. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT
WITH LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AND HELLO MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE I AM SENATOR
CORKER YOU KNOW THIS IS ADAM
WEST OF THE MOTION PICTURE
CUSTOMERS IATSE LOCAL SEVEN OH
FIVE AND I'LL BE UP BY TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS WE WRITE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS
ADAM. HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU
THAT'S GOOD EARNINGS CALL. NEXT
TO THE TWO LINES FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR- THIS IS SCOTT BERNARD
FROM IATSE LOCAL SIX NINE FIVE
STUDIO. PRODUCTION SOUND AND
VIDEO ENGINEERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PHONE
CALLS GOT PRECIADO NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANKS TO THE CLIENT
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS DINNER FOR MY ATSC LOCAL
EIGHT HUNDRED ART DIRECTORS
GUILD WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PREVIOUS
EFFORTS THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S GOING TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB ANY MOTION PICTURE
SET PAINTERS AND FINE WRITERS
IGST LOCAL SEVENTY NINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. SO MUCH BOB
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT TIME PLEASE
. NEXT TO THE TO LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GREGORY IS ORACLE SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. IS HE LEADING
TECHNICIANS AND- STRONG SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH X. COLOR
PLEASE. MEXICO GO TO LINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY WRITER GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE MET HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT NO MA'AM WE'RE IN
TROUBLE NOW GERRY SMITH IS
CALLED IN THANK YOU SO MUCH
JEREMY GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE
SIR GIVE OUR BEST EVERYONE.
THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT CALLER. THIS
TIME THERE'S NO NOTHING TO YOU.
ALL RIGHT MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH LADIES IN GERMAN WE DO HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO AND CHECKING TO SEE
IF WE HAVE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE TAKING. OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
WE DON'T HAVE ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS LISTED. AS A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. THAT WE'RE GONNA CHECK
IN HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB. FORTY
FIVE PLEASE STAND NOW. SEE NO
ONE RISES TO MODERATOR WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. CHECK IN TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL FORTY
FIVE IF YOU COULD PLEASE. QUEUE
THEM UP DOWN MR MODERATOR. IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF- BILL FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS. ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MODERATORS LET FOLKS QUEUE
UP WE'LL BE CHECKING BACK IN
WITH MODERATOR HOW WE LOOKING.
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE
WHO CALLED IN HERE TODAY- FOR-
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE. SIR
WINNER HAS ADVANCED A MOTION IS
THERE ANY CONVERSATION UP FROM
COMMITTEE MR VICE CHAIR THE
FORCE OR SIR HAPPY NEW YEAR
SHEERAN LOOKING FOR TO WORK WITH
YOU THIS YEAR. THE NEAREST
CHAIRMAN GOOD TO BE BACK. I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS IS I ALWAYS
HAVE THE BUT I WANT TO CHALLENGE
THE FILM INDUSTRY. TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE AND PARTICIPATORY IN
OPPOSING THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
DOES THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDERS
THAT HAVE MADE. CALIFORNIA SUCH
A TERRIBLE STATE TO DO BUSINESS
IN. EVEN THE LARGEST TECH
COMPANIES ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA
. AND THAT'S NOT IT IT'S A
MULTIPLE OF ACTIONS LEGISLATION
COMING THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE
AND EXECUTIVE ORDERS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND ONE OF THE
BIG PROBLEMS NOW IT'S KIND OF A
STEALTH ISSUE. THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY YEAR SHE NEEDS MORE OF THE
AUTHORITY OF THE PEOPLE. THE IT
THROUGH THEM TO THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH GIVING THEM UNILATERAL
AUTHORITY. TO MAKE DECISIONS
THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES SUPPOSEDLY BUT MOST
OF ITS COVERT AND SOMEONE THAT I
WOULD ARGUE EVEN IS UNDERGROUND
REGULATION. MY CHALLENGE THEN TO
THE FILM INDUSTRY YOU HAVE A
GREAT. POPE PAUL PUT OUT THERE.
DIVERGED SPEAKING UP AGAINST
THESE ACTIONS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND YOU BETTER START
DOING IT. YOU DON'T YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE DESERVING OF MORE
CREDIT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DESERVING OF LOSING THAT CREDIT
AND DESPITE HAVING TO SUFFER
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE SO THAT
THAT'S MY ADMONISHMENT TO THE
FILM INDUSTRY STAND UP AND
OPPOSE SOME OF THESE THINGS
DON'T JUST SUPPORT YOUR OWN
BENEFIT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER VICE CHAIR WE'RE GONNA
TURN OVER CENTER DRAWS A GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU MR CHAIR- AND
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IN HIS WORK LAST
YEAR- THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE THAT
I'VE BEEN ACQUAINTED WITH FOR
MANY YEARS- WHEN I WAS AT THE
ALLEY FEDERATION OF LABOR I
REMEMBER. THAT WE HAD TO GET
PAST THE PERCEPTION THAT ANY
KIND OF A TAX CREDIT WAS ONLY
GOING TO BENEFIT THE VERY
WEALTHY STUDIO- EXECUTIVES- AND
THAT WAS THE PICTURE THAT WAS
PAINTED SO THERE WAS NO
DESERVING OF ANY TAX CREDIT
BECAUSE IT WAS ONLY GOING TO
SERVE IT WAS ONLY GOING TO
SUPPORT THESE VERY HANDFUL OF
VERY WEALTHY PEOPLE WE HAD TO
GET THROUGH THAT AND IT TOOK A
LOT OF WORK TO SAY WAIT A
MINUTE. THIS INDUSTRY IS MADE UP
OF FAR MORE WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN BOTH IN FRONT OF CAMERA
BEHIND CAMERA ALL WHO REALLY-
CREATE YOU KNOW WHO WORK IN THE
JOBS THAT ARE SO GOOD FOR OUR
ECONOMY SO WELL PAID WITH
BENEFITS AND ALL OF THAT SO WE
GOT THROUGH THAT. GOT THE FIRST
TAX CREDITS AND WE'RE MOVING
ALONG NOW BUT WHAT- MY CONCERN
IS THAT- WE HAVE HAD A
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSIFY THE
WORKFORCE IN FRONT AND BEHIND
THE CAMERA AND IT REALLY HASN'T
HAPPENED TO ANY NOTICEABLE
DEGREE. THERE'S A FEW THINGS
HERE AND THERE. BUT I'M I'M
DISAPPOINTED THAT FAR MORE
DEEPER COMMITMENT HASN'T
RESULTED IN THE CHANGE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE. CALIFORNIA IS
KNOWN OF IN EVERY SINGLE WAY FOR
OUR DIVERSITY. AND THAT WORD IS
USED VERY LOOSELY BY SOME- BUT
I'M LOOKING FOR A DEEPER WAY IN
WHICH ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE
ACCESS. TO EVERY LEVEL OF THIS
INDUSTRY EVERY LEVEL- WE HAD A-
AND THE LATINO CAUCUS. A PANEL
ON UNSEEN LET THE IN HOUSE AND
WE HAD ONE DEDICATED TO THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IN WHICH
- WOMAN AFTER WOMAN LOOKING
AFTER LET THE NOTIN THE VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE INDUSTRY. TESTIFIED
AS TO HOW THEY WERE LOCKED OUT
HOW THEY WERE LEFT OUT HI THEY
WEREN'T GIVEN THE TOOLS THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE TO BE ABLE TO-
I'LL BE A PART OF THIS INDUSTRY
IN AND- OF. THEN WE HEARD
TESTIMONY ABOUT- THE PERCENTAGE
OF THE VARIOUS COMMUNITIES IN
THIS. IN THIS STATE AND AS
CONSUMERS. SO CONSUMERS
TAXPAYERS ON EVERY LEVEL ARE NOT
GETTING THE SAME ACCESS TO THESE
JOBS- I UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT
GIVING THIS TAX CREDIT BUT- AS
WE EXTENDED NOW TO TWENTY TWENTY
NINE WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US
HOW SERIOUS WILL THE INDUSTRY
TAKE. THE ISSUE OF MUCH DEEPER
OF COMMITMENT. TO MAKING THE
CHANGE AND HAVING THESEJOBS
AND- CAREERS OPENED UP TO
EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITY UP SO
I ALSO SAY TO YOU. THAT I GET
CALLS AND LETTERS AND MEETINGS
ALL THE TIME. UP FROM- THOSE FEW
WHO ARE. HAVE BEEN UNSUCCESSFUL
AND IT'S- THERE AND HAVING TO
RAISE MONEY PRIVATELY. FOR
PROGRAMS TO MENTOR YOUTH.
THEY'RE HAVING TO RAISE MONEY
PRIVATELY TO RAISE MONEY FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS SO THAT THEY COULD
GO TO SCHOOL TO BE ABLE TO.
ENTER THIS INDUSTRY I THINK
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND I REALLY
LIKE I COUNT ON THE AND THE
AUTHOR. AND THE CO AUTHORS- TO
BE MUCH MORE DEMANDING- ON THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE SHOULD HAVE I
DON'T WANT TO BE HERE IN FOUR
YEARS AND SAY WELL WE GOT A
REPORT AND WELL WE'LL KEEP
TRYING- YOU KNOW ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH WITH THAT SO. AGAIN ON
THE ONE HAND I AM UNEQUIVOCALLY
IN SUPPORT I APPRECIATE OF THE
AUTHOR AND- I SPECIALLY LOVE
THAT THEY ARE HIGHLY UNIONIZED
JOBS AND IN AN INDUSTRY- BUT WE
HAVE TO BE MUCH MORE SERVICE ON
THIS OTHER FRONT. SO THANK YOU
AND. I WOULD LOVE TO BE A
COLLECTIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER ALSO I'M TURN IT OVER TO
SEE TWENTY AND ABOUT SIXTY
SECONDS I'M JUST GONNA SAY ONE
OF THE ITEMS THAT I APPRECIATED%
AND FROM THE FEEDBACK WE HAD
ORIGINALLY WHEN THE SPILLS AND
PRODUCTIVITY. WHY IS ENSURING
THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY IN REGARD
TO THE PROJECTS THAT WE FELT-
AND A LOT OF AREAS IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA NEVER SIDE BENEFIT.
TO THE TAX CREDIT NAT IS
ACTUALLY CHANGING APPRECIATE
THAT RECORDING IF WE TAKE A LOOK
AT SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES PER
CAPITA PROPERTY- AND- CHALLENGES
WITH BUSINESS STARTS IS IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT I APPRECIATE
FROM THE INDUSTRY. IS THAT IS
BEING RACKED NOW- IN REPORTING
IS COMING BACK TO US SO AT TEN
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THANK YOU
BECAUSE THAT WASN'TAN ISSUE
THAT WE HAD LAST TIME- AND I
APPRECIATE YOU DRESSING THAT THE
INDUSTRY DRESSING THAT. WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE INVESTMENT IN.
ALL CORNERS OF THE STATE AND IT
IS LIFTING ALL BOATS-
THROUGHOUT- THE GOLDEN STATE IN
RURAL AND URBAN COMMUNITIES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT TURNED
OVER TO YOU FOR THE CLOTHES YOU
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU-
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES-
WE HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB AND
AS THIS BILL PROGRESSES- IT
WILL- YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MOVE IT OUT OF THE SENATE GIVEN
OUR DEADLINES AND TIMELINES. BUT
I EXPECTED CAN YOU HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WHEN IT'S OVER IN
THE ASSEMBLY SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS- AS BEEN SAID THIS
IS A VITAL INDUSTRY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE IMPACT
ON- UNION JOBS IMPACT ON MIDDLE
CLASS WORKERS AND THE IMPACT ON
THE ECONOMY ARE ALL MARRIED IN
MOVING THIS FORWARD AND SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIEND
ABOUT. TEN POINT YOU KNOW GOOD
DC CENTER STERN THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT'S IMPORTANT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
REALLY GOOD DISCUSSION BY
COMMITTEE TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND DRUGS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR SARA
WIENER. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR BY
CENTER WINNER. MR NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS.
TO RULES. NINE TEN THAT THE
MEASURE B. WE WERE. TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATE. PURSUANT
TO JOINT RULED POINT FIVE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. WHERE ARE
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN. REFLECTED
I. DEALS AND- A SENATOR DORADO.
TWO HOURS AGO- YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR WIENER. WINNER
HI AT THE FOUR ZERO VOTE LAYS IN
GERMAN FOR ZERO VOTE THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROOM
THANK YOU SO MUCH I CAN PRETTY
MUCH SAY TRAVELS HOME THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOONER STERN THERE'S A
GENTLEMAN WE GOT A DOUBLE HEADER
A DOUBLE HEADER OF SENATOR
WIENER HE'S GONNA BE PRESENTING
SP TWO SEVENTY ONE- AND THEN
HE'S ALSO BE PRESENTING SP THREE
SEVENTY NINE- WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK THIRTY SECOND BREAK AS-
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM CENSUS GO
SET UP. AND WE'LL GET STARTED
HERE IN THIRTY SECONDS.
ALL
RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. WE
ARE WELCOMING THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. AT TWO
BILLS. ONE ON JURIES. AT THE
SECOND. HE HAS BEEN WORKING ON.
GOSH SINCE THE BEGINNING OF LAST
YEAR- AND IT'S BACK HERE AT SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE THE FIRST
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING. ON SB
TWO SEVENTY ONE. SIR WE- HAVE
BEEN NEAR SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU THE FORESHORES. THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN. I CALLED SP TWO
SEVEN ONE IS- IT'S A- AN
EXPANSION. OF A BILL THAT I
AUTHORED AND WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
A FEW YEARS AGO SP FIVE NINETY
TWO. ARE YOU MAY RECALL- THE S.
P. FIVE EIGHT TWO. IT HAS TO DO
WITH- HOW WE DEFINE OUR JURY
POOL- THE PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA
AND BOTH STATE COURTS AND
FEDERAL COURTS. HAVE BEEN THE
SUMMONS JURY POOLS. USING THE
VOTER ROLLS. AND DMV FILES. AND
THAT IS- NOT EXPAND AND- IT
LEAVES A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF
SOMEONE DOESN'T HAVE A DRIVER'S
LICENSE. IF SOMEONE IS A
REGISTERED TO VOTE THEY WON'T
GET CALLED FOR JURY DUTY. AND SO
IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC DIVERSITY
AND RACIAL DIVRSITY- IT REALLY
MEANS THAT WE HAVE JURY POOLS
THAT ARE NOT. FULLY REFLECTIVE
OF THE COMMUNITY- AND SO WHEN WE
PASSED SB FIVE NINETY TWO- WE-
AUTHORIZED. THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO PROVIDE. TAXPAYER
FILES- TO OUR COUNTY JURY
COMMISSIONERS. SO THAT THE JURY
POOL WILL INCLUDE THE ENTIRE
TAXPAYER. DATABASE AND THAT'S
HOW IT'S JUST A MUCH BROADER-
CROSS SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY
AND SO THAT WAS PASSED- AND
THEN- LAST YEAR- THE FEDERAL
COURTS CAME TO US AND SAID. WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO EXPAND OUR
JURY POOLS BYE ARE THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TELLS US THE
LEGISLATION IS REQUIRED. TO
AUTHORIZE THE TRANSFER OF THAT
DATA TO THE FEDERAL COURTS. AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE TWO SEVENTY
ONE IS IT SIMPLY EXPANDS SP FIVE
NINETY TWO ALSO AUTHORIZED
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TO PROVIDE
DATA SUBJECT TO SOME PRETTY
STRICT CONFIDENTIALITY- I'M
PROTECTIVE MEASURES. I TO THE
FEDERAL COURTS- AND SO THAT'S
THE GIST OF THIS- BILL LIKE IF
THEY WERE ALREADY DOING THIS NOW
IN STATE COURT- AND IF HE MAKES
ALL THE SENSE IN THE WORLD. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF DOING I SHOULD
NOTE. THAT IN EXPANDING OUR
GROUP PULLS TO THE TAXPAYER
DATABASE CALIFORNIA WAS NOT THE
FIRST STATE TO DO THAT A NUMBER
OF OTHER STATES ALREADY DO IT SO
THIS IS. A PRACTICE THAT IS I'VE
BEEN GROWING AND WE SHOULD. I
CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD. FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK- I. UP WITH-
TODAY WERE THE VERSION TODAY IF
- ARE- JUDGE- WILL. ALSUP WHO A
SENIOR JUDGE. ON THE U. S.
DISTRICT COURT FOR THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA I WILL
SAY WHEN I WAS A DEPUTY CITY
ATTORNEY I APPEARED BEFORE JUDGE
ALSUP- MANY MANY TIMES HE IS A
TOUGH AND FAIR A JUDGE THE
WALKING JUDGE ALSUP. AND THEN
WE'LL ALSO HEAR FROM LIZ KNOW
WHERE- THE DIRECTOR OF ROOM
OPERATIONS FOR THE US DISTRICT
COURT FOR THE NORTHERN DISTRICT
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR WIENER LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN COMMITTEE AND WE WANT
TO REMIND YOU OF ANYONE LIKE A
BETTER PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING YOU CAN CALL THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER WE WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE'RE GONNA PUT
THAT. TOLL FREE NUMBER UP ON THE
SCREEN WE DO WELCOME
PARTICIPATION REMOTELY HERE
TODAY. AT LADIES IN GERMAN AS
CENTER WINNER HAD JUST STATED WE
HAVE TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT JUDGE ALSUP IS
WITH US HE'S A SENIOR DISTRICT
JUDGE IN THE U. S. DISTRICT
COURT FOR THE NORTHERN DISTRICT
OF CALIFORNIA. JUDGE WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE- AND WE WELCOME
YOUR COMMENTS ON S. B. TWO
SEVENTY ONE YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE. YOU ARE NOW LIVE JUDGE. OKAY
THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU HELLO
ME AT. TO BE THESE KIND. I DON'T
HAVE A FEDERAL JUDGE SAN
FRANCISCO FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
TEN OF THOSE YEARS I WAS THE
CHAIR OF OUR JURY COMMITTEE.
WELL I WAS. WE HAVE BECOME VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS- APART FROM
JUST BEING A TRIAL JUDGE. AND
RUNNING- JURY TRIALS. THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM IS THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE THIS DEVOTION A
JURY POOL AS WE CAN POSSIBLY GET
. AND USING THE TRADITIONAL
METHODS FALLS A LITTLE BIT SHORT
AND THE TRADITIONAL METHODS ARE
BOLDER. REGISTRATION ROLES AS
WELL AS THE N. B. RECORDS. THE
PROBLEM IS THE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THE MOVE AROUND MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN OTHERS AND THEREFORE THE
ADDRESSES THAT THEY LEAVE BEHIND
WITH B. AND B. FOR EXAMPLE
BECOME OUT OF DATE SHOW THE
WORLD OUR JURY SUMMONS GOES TO
THAT ADDRESS IT- THEY'RE NO
LONGER THERE. AND SO WE NEED THE
MOST CURRENT ADDRESSES. THAT WE
CAN GET. AND THE TAX. ROLLS FROM
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WILL BE
A TREMENDOUS- EDITION SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE MORE UP TO DATE
ADDRESSES FOR OUR JURY SUMMONS.
THIS IS NOT OUR PROBLEM IS
EXACTLY THE SAME PROBLEM THAT
YOU HAD PREVIOUS WILL ADDRESS
THAT WITH THE SP FIVE NINETY
TWO. AND. REALLY ALL WE'RE
ASKING IS THAT THE- THAT SAME
CODE DO OF F. T. B. THE EX TO
THE FEDERAL. FOR THE BETTER
COURT CAN. COMBINE THAT DATA
BASE WITH THE ONES THAT WERE
ALREADY USING- FOR THIS CONCEPT
AND WE- VERY MUCH ASKING YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION- S. B.
TWO SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU JUDGE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE WITH THIS KNOW HOW
BUSY YOU ARE IN YOR TESTIMONY
MEANS A LOT THANK YOU SO MUCH
JUDGING HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU
PLACE IN GENERAL ANOTHER MOVING
ON TO LOSE NO WHERE SHE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF COURTROOM OPERATIONS
FOR THE U. S. DISTRICT COURT FOR
THE NORTHERN DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA. IS NOT WHERE WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW LIVE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. IS NOT WHERE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. AND B. TWO SEVENTY
ONE GOING TO BENEFIT THE STATE
BY MAKING A FEDERAL JURY MORE
CLOSELY REPRESENT THE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES WHICH- I'LL JUST
BUILD BRIEFLY ON THE POINT. THE
JUDGE OUT THAT THAT THAT.
PROFESSOR SAM SUMMERS UP HEALTH
UNIVERSITY FOUND IN A TWO
THOUSAND SIX RESEARCH STUDY THAT
RACIALLY DIVERSE JURY RAISED A
BROADER RANGE OF QUESTIONS AND.
MADE FEWER FACTUAL ERRORS. AND
MEDIC MANY YOUR ALL LEADERSHIP-
TO DIVERSIFYING JERRY WHEN HIS
COURT ADDED TO D. AND E. LET
YOUR ORIGINAL VOTER.
REGISTRATION FIRST LEFT. BACK IN
THE EARLY NINETIES WE SAW AN
IMMEDIATE IMPROVEMENT IN THE
REPRESENTATION OF BLACKS LATINOS
AND ASIAN AMERICANS AND ARE
QUALIFIED JURY POOL. WE RECENTLY
HAD EXPERTS FROM THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR JURY STUDIES ANALYZE
THEIR JURY POOL AND THEY FOUND
THAT INCLUSION OF ANOTHER SOURCE
LIST WOULD BRING THE COURT EVEN
CLOSER TO ITS GOAL AND
REFLECTING THE COMMUNITY. WHICH
IN TURN INCREASES PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN VERDICTS RENDERED
BY OUR FEDERAL OR CALIFORNIA
FEDERAL JURY. YEAH DOWN THE
DETAILS OF THE ALLEGED TAX
FILERS FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD IT'S GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL- IN ADDING
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEITHER ARE
REGISTERED TO VOTE NOR HAVE THE
AMBULANCE BUT ALSO IF YOU SPENT.
IN GETTING UP FRENCH YOUR
ADDRESS ALMOST 20% OF THE
SUMMONSES THAT OUR COURT AND
THAT ARE RETURNED UNDELIVERABLE
BY THE POST OFFICE. AND NEED
UNDELIVERABLE FAMINE DOES COME
FOR MORE MOBILE CALIFORNIANS
GENERALLY RANCHERS WHO TEND TO
BE MORE MINORITY AND LOW INCOME
SO WE THINK THAT BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS ARE REQUIRED YOU
INTERACT WITH THE FTP YEARLY. AT
THE ADDRESSES. WILL BE MORE
ACCURATE. I MANY. DON'T MISS
BETWEEN THE AND FEDERAL THE WHEN
IT. TO JURY DUTY THEY JUST KNOW
THAT THEY'VE BEEN CALLED SISTER.
AND WE THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
STATE AND FEDERAL- JURY POOL
SHOULD BE ON THE SAME FOOTING.
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY PROBABLY
IMPORTANT THAT EXPANDING THE
POOL OF INDIVIDUALS CALLED ON
JURIES WHEN IT PASSED F. B. FIVE
NINETY TWO. AND WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR WIENER FOR
BRINGING ATHLETES YOU SEVENTY
ONE WHICH AS YOU SAID IN THE
COMMON SENSE STEPS TO INCLUDE
FEDERAL COURT AND THAT EXTENSION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS IT WORTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL IT'S GOOD TO HEAR VOICE
HAVE A DOZEN GERMAN OF COMMITTEE
WE ARE NOW GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF SP. TWO SEVENTY ONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE AT THIS TIME.
SEEING KNOWING. WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINER LIVE LINE. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO SEVENTY ONE
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB TWO SEVENTY ONE NOW. IF YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MODERATORS AND- WANTING TO YOU.
KNOW ANYTHING CUTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH I MISS A MODERATOR
APPRECIATE DATABASE IN
GERMANTOWN AND BRING IT BACK TO
BE A TO SEE. IF THERE IS ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION I WANT TO FIRST
SAY THAT WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH IS ON RECORD.
WE'RE GONNA CHECK HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE DAYS IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SP TWO
SEVENTY ONE. IF YOU COULDPLEASE
RISE. SEEN KNOWING RISE WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MR
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB TWO SEVENTY
ONE NOW. ACTUALLY IF YOU LIKE TO
COME IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SEVENTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOW THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE CENTER DROPPED TO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO BY THE
WA IN THE PAST FRIDA- SHIRT. I
LOVE THAT AS I WAS TELLING HER
ON THE FLOOR TODAY- MY MOM AND I
WENT TO HER HOUSE LIKE THREE
YEARS AGO WHICH WAS JUST
SPECTACULAR SO. LOVE THAT. HE
ABSOLUTELY REMARKABLY BETTER
BELIEVE IT. I'M SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR- BY CENTER
DRAWS OF ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. HEARINGS C. NINE-
MISTER WINNER YOU HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFUL
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND A WINNER AND DO APPRECIATE
YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS
IMPORTANT CAUSE- MOTION BY
CENTER DRIVE SO WE'RE GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO MR NOW TO GET A CALL
THE ROLE IN THE FORMAL MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
WIRE I SENATOR NIELSEN NO.
YOU'LL SOON NO SENATOR TORONTO.
TORONTO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER ALL RIGHT WE-
BASIN GENTLEMAN THAT IS A THREE
ONE VOTE THREE ONE VOTE THE BILL
PASSES THE BILL IS OUT RECALLS
IN THE ROLE WE'RE CLOSE IN THE
ROLE AND SP TWO SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AMBER'S AGAIN
THIS IS A DOUBLE HEADER- BY
SENATOR WIENER. CENTER WINNER
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR GOSH A TWO
YEARS NOW I KNOW THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE BEEN SOMETHING I SAID THE
CENTER WINNER WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BILL PRIOR TO THE
HEARING. HE HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
DEDICATED TO BE ABLE TO WORK OUT
AND IT'S GOING TO BE HONEST TO
WORK OUT SOME OF THE WRINKLES
OUT WITH THIS ISSUE AND THERE
HAVE BEEN WRINKLES AND CENTER
WINNER YOU HAVE BEEN DEDICATED
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH- SOME OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WITH THIS
BILL I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT- IT IS BEEN A
REALLY PERSONAL FOR YOU. AND HE
BRINGS BACK AN AMENDED BILL HERE
FOR S. B. THREE SEVENTY NINE-
FOR ENTERTAINMENT BY THIS
COMMITTEE HI SIR WHENEVER
INTERNAL READY. AT I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER CHAIRMAN- SO-
SP THREE SEVEN NINE IS SIMILAR
TO A BILL THAT. WAS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR- SP SIX ONE
SEVEN- IT DOES NOT CONTAIN THE
FUNDING PEACE ANYMORE BECAUSE
THAT WAS PLACED IN THE BUDGET.
LAST YEAR GRANT PROGRAM FOR
CITIES TO HELP THEM. IMPLEMENT
OUR AUTOMATED- AUTOMATED- SOLAR-
PERMITTING. I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE IS A SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT IN THE ANALYSIS- WERE
WE'RE GOING TO. I BELIEVE THE
ACCEPTING THAT A MOMENT
INDIGENOUS VERY. ARE INVESTING
IN THE ENERGY COMMITTEE. ARE
THERE WAS ENOUGH TIME TO GET IN
IN THIS COMMITTEE- SO COLLEAGUES
SP THREE SEVENTY NINE- REQUIRES-
JURISDICTION. ABOVE A CERTAIN
SIZE- TO IMPLEMENT AUTOMATED
ONLINE SOLAR PERMITTING PROCESS
HE'S- FOR SIMPLE RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP. SOLAR AND SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE SYSTEMS I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THAT THIS IS ABOUT.
MALL SIMPLE BASIC SOLAR AND
SOLAR STORAGE SYSTEMS ON
RESIDENTIAL. ROOFTOPS ISN'T
ABOUT LARGER. OR MORE
COMPLICATED SYSTEMS IT'S NOT
ABOUT. A BIG APARTMENT BUILDINGS
IT'S NOT ABOUT COMMERCIAL. THIS
IS REALLY FOR SMALL SINGLE
FAMILY DUPLEX. A ROOFTOP SYMBOL
OUR SOLAR SYSTEM THE KIND OF.
BEEN GETTING INSTALLED IN
CALIFORNIA. ART. FOR DECADES- SO
ARE WE SO IS A CRITICAL OF.
FUTURE INCOME IN TERMS OF
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS- AND
WE HAVE ADOPTED ALL SORTS OF
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
ENCOURAGE- SOLAR AND ROOFTOP
SOLAR- AND WE KNOW THE COST OF
SOLAR HAS BEEN GOING DOWN MAKING
IT ACCESSIBLE TO MORE MORE
PEOPLE- THAT'S THE HARD COSTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SOFT COSTS AND
HAVE NOT BEEN GOING DOWN NEARLY
SO MUCH I'M PART OF THE SOFT
COSTS IS THAT THE PERMITTING
TIME PERIOD. CAN SOMETIMES BE
WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS AND
SOMETIMES THE SYSTEM IS
INSTALLED IT SO SIMPLE SYSTEM-
THAT WILL BE PERMITTED BUT IT
CAN'T BE TURNED ON FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME IT'S-
IT'S REALLY UNNECESSARY. A
BARRIER- SO AUTOMATED- SOLAR
PERMITTING IT'S SOMETHING I HAVE
BEEN PIONEERED FRANKLY BY THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY- AND SECRETARY GROUND
HOME HAS BEEN A REAL CHAMPION
FOR THIS- THE U. THE- DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY- CREATED. SOMETHING
CALLED SOUL SOLAR OUT PLUS WHICH
WAS CREATED AS PART OF A VERY
BROAD STAKEHOLDER PROCESS- AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL ON THIS BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE USE THAT
CITIES ADOPT. SOLAR APP PLUS YOU
CAN BE AT ANY KIND OF SIMILAR-
BUT WE EXPECTED SOLAR PLUS WILL
BE THE ONE THAT CITIES WILL USE
BECAUSE IT'S A- WAS. PUT
TOGETHER IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL-
AND SOLID WAY- AND THIS WILL-
ALLOW FOR FASTER A PERMITTING WE
KNOW THE LOS ANGELES. AND SAN
JOSE AND STOCKED IN OTHER CITIES
ARE ALREADY- ALLOWING- AUTOMATED
ONLINE SOLAR PERMITTING- AND
THIS WILL EXPAND THAT TO THE
REST OF THE STATE EXEMPTING OUT
THE SMALLER CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AND THEN ALSO PROVIDING A TIME
FOR WOMAN TO- FOR CITIES THAT
ARE IN. BUT ARE ON THE SMALLER.
SIDE THIS IS FOR A PLUS IT'S
FREE AND IT'S OPEN SOURCE IT'S
EASY TO IMPLEMENT- THIS IS
REALLY A VERY POSITIVE STEP IN
TERMS OF THE SORT OF PUSHING OUR
STATE. TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION- CITIES WILL STILL BE
ABLE TO DO INSPECTIONS- IF THEY
WANT TO ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
IT'S NOT. UPPER CLOSED WE DID
WORK LAST YEAR WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS WHICH
ARE CONTINUE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL WE ALSO WORK LAST YEAR
WITH IBEW. AND CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS ON
AMENDMENTS TO CAUSE THEM TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE STILL IN THIS
BILL IN TOTAL- ANSWER CALLING
THIS IS A GOOD BILL WHOSE TIME
HAS COME. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. WITH ME- BY PHONE TO
TESTIFY TODAY OR NEXT TO SEVERAL
WHAT'S THE CHIEF OF POLICY- AND
LAURA- D. HAN WHO IS THE STATE
DIRECTOR AT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA VIEWS WITH TWO CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IN THE WINTER AND AGAIN
I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK FROM
THE LAST TIME WE SAW THIS BILLS
IN WINTER AND I HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT. COULD
SMALLER IN RULE JURISDICTIONS
ROLL THIS OUT AND HE WORKED WITH
US ON THAT AS HE ALWAYS DOES.
SHE DIED AND NOW WORKING THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ADDITIONAL ITEMS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONTINUED TO DILIGENCE ON THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO NICK
JOSEPH WHAT'S- THAT MR JOSEPH
WHAT'S IT'S REALLY GOOD TO HEAR
YOU- IN HERE YOUR VOICE WERE
GRATEFUL YOUR COMMITTEE CHIEF.
OF POLICY FOR SPARE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES SIR AND I'LL GIVE YOU A. THIRTY SECOND PROMPT YOU'RE
NOT ALIVE AND HAPPY NEW YEAR.
HAPPY NEW YEAR YOU SO- BUT YOU
YOU WENT TO YOUR COMMITTEE STAR
TO WORK US SO PRODUCTIVELY OF
THE SPELL AND ITS PRE DISCUSSED
THE LAW YEAH. AND OF COURSE
THANK YOU DEFENDED A WE HAD HIS
STUFF FOR THAT LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. STARR IS CO
SPONSORING SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
WITH ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO.
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
THE CDC JOIN ME WITH THE PC IN
COSTA MESA CALIFORNIA WILL BE
TRIPLE THE AMOUNT OF SOLAR TO
MEET A 100% CLEAN ELECTRICITY
GO. THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
SATELLITE UPSTATE. IT TO MAKE IT
QUICKER AND CHEAPER TO INSTALL
SIMPLE RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR
SYSTEMS. DESPITE TALK
LEGISLATIVE REFORMS IT STILL
COST TOO MUCH AND TAKES TOO LONG
TO PERMIT THE TEMPLE RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP SOLAR SYSTEM. COSTING
THE TYPICAL CUSTOMER SEVERAL
THOUSAND EXTRA DOLLARS. THE
SOLUTION IS TO BUILD ON THE
SUCCESS OF DOZENS OF
JURISDICTIONS OF ALL SIZES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WHO HAVE
AUTOMATED THE PROMISING
POTENTIAL RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP
SOLAR SYSTEMS. THE CITY TO
APPROVE MORE APARTMENTS POSTED
MORE PRODUCT FEE REVENUE. AND
INSTALLED MORE SO AS A RESULT.
S. T. SEVENTY NINE LACK BACK
DIRECT EVEN COUNTY OF RESEARCH
POPULATION PRESS. TO IMPLEMENT
AUTOMATED CALL OF THING JUSTIN
RATHER THAN ROUTES SOLAR SOME OF
STORAGE SYSTEM. TO AUTOMATE
PROMPTING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
CAN USE FREE SOFTWARE DEVELOPED
BY THE NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
LAB ACROSS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CALLED SO AFTER WHAT.
THE SOFTWARE WAS DEVELOPED WITH
THE COUNTRY'S MOST RESPECTIVE
BUILDING SAFE YOUR THANKS. THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL INSPECTORS THE
NATIONAL FIRE PROTECTION
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL CODE COUNCIL. AND
COOPERATES OER A. HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE SEPARATE PLAN
CHECKS. IMPORTANT LOCAL KIRSTY
ONLY NEEDED EMAIL TO FIND TO USE
THE SERVER AFTER. THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION WILL ALSO HAVE
A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
PROGRAM FULLY FUNDED OUT OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET TO COMPENSATE
JURISDICTIONS TO ANY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADOPTED
AUTOMATED SO ACCOMMODATING. THIS
BILL IS NOT AN UNFUNDED MANDATE
THIRTY SECONDS WITH SP THREE
SEVENTY NINE CALIFORNIA HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE MAJOR
STRIDES TO POWERING ALL STATE
WITH A 100% CLEAN ENERGY AT NO
ADDITIONAL COST WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR WORK AS WELL- AND WE HAVE-
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED THE
ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
LAURA D. HAND SHE'S A STATE
DIRECTOR FOR ENVIRONMENT%
CALIFORNIA MISTY AND WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE HAPPY NEW YEAR
TO YOU YOU ARE NOW LIVE. FIFTY
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. AND
I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. THANK YOU SO MUCH HAPPY
NEW YEAR TO YEAR WEALTHCARE MIKE
WEIR AND TWO COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
MY NAME'S ALREADY HAD. DIRECTOR
WITH ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
EIGHT WHITE. ENVIRONMENTAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WORKING
FOR CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER WILL
CONFIGURE THAN A LIVABLE PLANET.
AND WE'RE REALLY THRILLED TO BE
WORKING WITH FIRE AND SENATOR
WIENER CONTRACT THE EIGHTY
SEVENTY NINE THE LACK THAT FACT.
AND YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
ONE OF THE FUNNIEST PLACES IN
THE WORLD AND THE FLAG THE WAVE
WITH ROOFTOP SOLAR GROWTH. NOW
WITH OVER A MILLION SOLAR ROOFS
ACROSS THE STATE. I'VE GOT TO
GET. OUR 100% CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
WE NEED MORE ROOFTOP SOLAR. AND
YOU KNOW IT ONE OF THE BEST TYPE
OF ENERGY IN THE MOST POPULAR
BECAUSE IT CAUSES NO AIR
POLLUTION. IT CAUSES NO SALES IN
OUR BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE AND
THERE'S NO NEW LAND YET. AND OUR
POTENTIAL TO EXPAND ROOFTOP
SOLAR IT'S REALLY ENORMOUS WE
COULD ACTUALLY MEET THREE
QUARTERS. OF OUR ELECTRICITY
NEEDS JACK BY.CATCHING THE
THOUGHT ON EXISTING ROOFTOP. AND
BUT AS OTHERS HAVE DADS AFTER Q.
LONG AS PROSPECTING SOLAR PERMIT
HAS REALLY BURN AGAIN. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH HOURS OF
PAPERWORK FOR APPLICATION. AND
AS A RESULT CONSUMERS HAVE
REALLY EXPERIENCED DELAYS
IMPACTING. THEIR SOLAR PANELS.
ON THEIR BEDS. AND THAT'S WHY
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY TO
BALANCE THE OLDER APPS AND THIS
PAST SUMMER WHEN SECRETARY
JENNIFER GRANHOLM CAME TO
CALIFORNIA. AS PART OF HER
SUMMER OF FUN HERE AND TO
CELEBRATE AHMED. OKAY YOU KILLED
MAKE INSTALLING. SOLAR PANELS
CHEAPER FASTER AND EVEN MORE
POPULAR. AND SO AND THANKS TO
THE STATE LEGISLATURES IN BACK.
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
WILL HAVE A GREAT YOU GRANT
PROGRAM. WITH THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN I THOUGHT THAT
THAT THAT. WE REALLY SEE THAT
CRAFTING XP THREE SEVENTY NINE
IS THE MAX THAT. CATALYZE
ADOPTION AND ENSURE THAT ACROSS
OUR STATE. IF YOU THINK I NEED
TAKE ADVANTAGE. IN THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE THAT IS IN GERMAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE TURNING TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE ACTIVISTS SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
RISE. SCENE KNOWN RICE BLAZING
GENERAL COMMITTEE WERE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH THE MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR. WORD CHECK IN WITH
YOU ONE LAST TIME HERE TODAY AND
ONE LAST BILL SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE. IF YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
NOW. IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND FIRST WE GO TO LINE.
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KIM JONES STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION INTO THE ETHICS OF
COURT. THANK YOU SO MUCH CAME TO
ITS GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANCE WHERE AT MY JOB WITH THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S
GOOD TURNING SCHOLAR. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JENNIFER CALLING CASTLE CALLING
AT THE PORT AND- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S GOOD OR AN EXCELLENT. SHE
LIKES TO GO TO LINE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AND HAPPY NEW YEAR TURN MEMBERS
OFTEN PHOENICOPTERIFORMESFAMILY
HAPPENED- ENERGY AND SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION OR
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
THE TREE LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY ONE YOU'RE
IN COMMITTEE. MORNING THIS IS-
JENNIFER WE ON BEHALF OF
PALMETTO SOLAR CALLING IN CHARGE
FOR THE THREE SERENA THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROGER DICKINSON FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KARINA
GONZALEZ WITH HAMMOND CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS AND SUPPORT. YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT ONE. THANKS TO THE TWO LINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LIVE IN COMMITTEE
. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KATHERINE WITH GOD'S SAKE
REPRESENTING SENT OVER ENERGY
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CATHERINE APPRECIATE THAT LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO THE TO LINE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KATE MARTEL OF
REPRESENTING SUNPOWER
CORPORATION CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVENTY NINE THANK
YOU THANKS SO MUCH KATE. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE TWO
LINES SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALAN
FIELDCINEMA SOLAR USER AND
SOLAR INDUSTRY EMPLOYEE AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEGATIVE NINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
SUNNY **** PROVISIONING AURORA
SOLAR AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVENTY. I
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KERRY GERBER FOUNDER OF
SUNLIGHT IN POWER. SOLAR DESIGN
AND INSTALLATION FOR THE
BERKELEY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE TIME THERE'S
NO NOTHING Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. ARE ON RECORD HERE
TODAY WE WANT TO REMIND FOLKS WE
HAVE ONE LAST OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE
OPINION ON SP THREE SEVENTY NINE
WERE JUST ABOUT TO GO TO. OUR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION WE DO
HAVE A TOLL FREE NUMBER THAT
WE'RE GONNA PUT UP ON THE SCREEN
NOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO BETTER
PARTICIPATE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR ALL
RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK TODAY WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE NOW. YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THIRTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND WE DO HAVE SOME
MORE TO END UP JUST A MOMENT ALL
RIGHT NO WORRIES. P. SHEET THAT. MEISTER NIELSON EVEN DOING
WELL. DOING WELL ALL RIGHT HERE
WE GO ANOTHER YEAR OR BACK.
CENTER WINNER I THINK IT WOULD
LINE THIRTY SIX. AT. GOOD
MORNING BRITAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND-
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM BUT I
WILL SAY IT WANTED TO THANK YOU
ON THURSDAY AND I CAN- WHEN YOUR
DOCTORS FOR BEING VERY OPEN
ABOUT THIS BILL WE HAVE AGREED
ON SOME AMENDMENTS AND WE'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THEM IN
FRANCE BUT FOR NOW WE ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
AND HE'LL BE AMONG PARENTS
FRIENDS AND THEN WE WILL BE
REMOVING OPPOSITION SO. THANKS
FOR THE DIALOGUE AND BUT BUT-
RECORDS. THE NEW AMENDMENT IN
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE TODAY AND HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
YOU THANK YU FOR CALLING AND
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR GREAT JOB
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU. FOLKS I
JUST WANNA REMIND FOLKS- THERE
WILL BE AMENDMENTS AND THEN MEN
IN COMMENT THREE- WITH. IN THE
NARRATIVE THAT YOU'RE PROVIDED-
IN THE BACKGROUND. AND DO
APPRECIATE THE GOOD SENATOR FOR
WORKING WITH US. BUT THAT COULD
BE TO SEE IF THERE IS. A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR. TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THE BILL. TO MOVE. THEIR DRUG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DOING YEAH
PLEASE FIRE AWAY. OKAY I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND- LET YOU
KNOW. BUT CAN YOU TAKE A MINUTE
AND IF IT TAKES LONGER TAN THAT
WE CAN DO IT OFFLINE- JUST TO.
EXPLAIN WHAT WOULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE FOR THE ACTUAL.
HOMEOWNER RESIDENT. THE CHANGE
TO THIS. YEAH THE SYSTEM UP YOU
KNOW AS CONSUMERS WHAT DO THEY
LOOK FORWARD TO. PRICE CHANGES.
IT'LL IT'LL JUST BE. FASTER THE
RIGHT NOW. IF YOU- YOU'RE
WORKING WITH A VENDOR AND THEY
COME AND INSTALL. THE SYSTEM-
THE- RIGHT NOW THEY CAN TAKE. IF
YOU'RE LUCKY IT TAKES A FEW
DAYS. TO GET A PERMIT- IT MIGHT
TAKE WEEKS OR MONTHS
UNFORTUNATELY I MEAN YOU'RE JUST
SITTING THERE WITH THE SYSTEM
BUT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED. TO TURN
ON IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING FOR THE
CONSUMER- AND IN FACT- THE WE
WERE TOLD THAT. THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WALKED AWAY FROM EVEN DOING
IT IF THEY THINK IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LONG TIME. THIS WILL
ALLOW IT TO BE ESSENTIALLY
INSTANTANEOUS UNLESS THERE'S
SOME ISSUE. THAT CAUSES THE CITY
TO WANT TO DO AN INSPECTION- BUT
IT WILL BE EFFECTIVELY
INSTANTANEOUS ARE ON THE SAME
DAY. SO FOR THE CONSUMER TO MUCH
THAT'S FRUSTRATING- PROCESS-
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES LIKE
SOMETIMES GETTING THE- PG&E
ERROR I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO PG&E.
TO ACTUALLY- DO THE
INTERCONNECTION CAN ALSO TAKE.
TIME BUT THIS IS THIS WILL
REMOVE TIME FOR THE PERMITTING
AND ELIMINATE THAT. SOURCE OF
THE LION FRUSTRATION FOR THE
SIMPLE. SOLAR AND STORAGE
SYSTEMS. RIGHT AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE. RIGHT
REMOTELY OR BY VIDEOTAPE THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE THAT A HOMEOWNER
WILL BE. YOU CAN JUST EXPLAIN
THAT PART OF THE S. OF A THE
CONTRACTOR WOULD BE THE ONE TO
DO IT WOULD BE ABLE TO GO TEST
ONLINE AND JUST GET THE PERMIT-
ONLINE- INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
AUTOMATICALLY GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS AGAIN CITY STILL HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY. IF THEY THINK
THAT THERE'S A PARTICULAR ISSUE
THAT THEY NEED TO DO AN
INSPECTION- THEY CAN DO THAT BUT
IT WON'T BE AN AUTOMATIC THING
THAT HAPPENS- EVERY EVERY TIME.
AND ANY OTHER AND THE RATIONALE
IS THAT FOR THE VERY SIMPLE
SYSTEMS IT'S SORT OF LIKE IF YOU
THINK BACK IN THE DAY WHEN
DISHWASHERS WERE FIRST INVENTED-
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT OKAY WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE PLUGGING IT INTO THE
PLUMBING SYSTEM OR WHAT I CREATE
ISSUES. OBVIOUSLY TODAY WE DON'T
REQUIRE EVEN REQUIRE A PERMIT
FOR DOING THAT SO OVER TIME FOR
THE SIMPLE SYSTEMS IT'S SUCH A
ROUTINE THING AND IS THERE
AREN'T SORT OF UNEXPECTED
SURPRISES TYPICALLY PRETTY
SIMPLE SYSTEMS NOT PROBABLY
LIMITED ONLY TO RESIDENTIAL
SMALL SIMPLE SYSTEM- AND SO THE
AUTOMATION AUTOMATED PROGRAM
WILL JUST MAKE A MUCH. SMOOTHER
AND FASTER APPROVAL. NOTHING YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL SENATOR.
THIS VENTURE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR PLEASE MR MOISTURE
. YES I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
AUTHOR FROM BEING ONE OF THE
BEST AUTHORS I'VE EVER KNOWN HE
SO THOROUGHLY AND- I JUST
DELIVERED A WORKING ON HIS
LEGISLATION. MY OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE AUTHOR. BUT TO THE INDUSTRY
FOR DECADES AND I HAVE SUPPORTED
ALL OF IT THE SOLAR INDUSTRY IS
THOUGHT BENEFITS THAT WOULD HELP
THAT INDUSTRY GIRL. AND THEY'VE
JUST ALMOST ALL PAST. BUT I'VE
TALKED WITH SOME OF THE
PROVIDERS SAYING YOU KNOW I'M
GETTING TIRED OF YOU SEEKING
YOUR OWN BENEFITS THAT YOU DON'T
HELP OTHER FORMS OF ENERGY
GENERATION LIKE CO GENERATION
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED.
PROTECTED FOR CLEANING UP OUR
FORCES AND OUR WILD LANDS IN THE
SOLAR INDUSTRY GREEDILY JUST
TAKES CARE OF ITSELF AND DOESN'T
WORRY ABOUT OTHER SOURCES OF
POWER. AND I'M NOT NOT NOT OING
TO SUPPORT ANYTHING MORE FOR
SEWER UNTIL LIGHT INDUSTRY STEPS
UP AND TRIES TO HELP US OUT IN
OTHER AREAS OF ENERGY IN.
CALIFORNIA AND THAT INCLUDES
FOSSIL FUELS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MEASURE APPRECIATE THAT-
SCENE THAT WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE DICE CENTER WINNER AND
HAVE YOU CLOSE PLEASE- RESPECT
FOR PRIVATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RIGHT LISTEN JOHN SP THREE
SEVENTY NINE AGAIN DO APPRECIATE
THE WORK BY CENTER WINNER WILL
BE TAKING AN AMENDMENT THERE IN
ENERGY COMMITTEE. MR CONNEL IF
YOU CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
I DO THE FORMER MOTION. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATION. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI. WIRE SENATOR NIELSEN NO
YOU'LL SON NO SENATOR TORONTO
HI THEY'RE ALSO- A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER HI
WINNER- THANK YOU GENTLEMEN WE
GOT A THREE ONE THREE ONE VOTE
THE BILL PASSES THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE. HEY
HAPPY NEW YEAR EVERYBODY- VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE GODS IN FIVE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. HERE
IN THE ROOM WITH US TODAY WE
HAVE COLIN IN ITS L. VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR WORK WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE I. T. TEAM
AND OF COURSE THE SERGEANTS-
INTO CAUCUS AT FOR THEIR
CONTINUED. SUPPORT AND WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
EVERYONE HAS A WONDERFUL WEEKEND
WE WILL SEE YOU HERE. NEXT WEEK
NOT. FOR ADDITIONAL SANITATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOUR YEAH.